all right tracy
tracy oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally milton florida
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were a kid um
not really i mean there were
probably maybe three or four years
combined
that i was with them um i was in foster
homes
and children's homes and lived with
family for most of my
childhood how would you describe your
childhood
lonely
not all foster families are what they're
cracked up to be
some of them are in it for the money and
they don't care
about the children that are there there
were a couple of them where we were
actually abused
um used for
maids to clean and
take care of the house and take care of
the kids and stuff like that
i didn't get to see my mom very
very much she stayed with my dad
and it was
mainly me and my brother and sister so
we became real close to three of us
when we were little um and then
some of the foster homes they put my
brother
and one and then kept me and my sister
um together and everything
so and my
grandparents about my fifth grade
um came and got custody of me my brother
and sister
i'm the oldest and um
we went and stayed with them for about a
year to between
our grandparents and aunts and uncles
so it was really topsy-turvy you know
you don't
know where you're going to be the
my family really showed us love and
stuff and understanding
because they knew everything that we had
been through
and the places that we had been at the
foster in the foster homes
and with my dad and my mom's
ex-boyfriend
and so they were real loving and
supportive and things like that and then
we got too old for our grandparents to
take care of
so we got put in um a children's home in
tallahassee
um where we stayed for about
four years three or four years
and then my mom came back
and um we stayed with her
from my ninth grade year until i
graduated
and then i moved out my ninth grade my
12th grade year
i moved out so you mentioned something
that happened with your
your father and your your stepdad my
father
began molesting me when
um i had to have been
four because i remember my sister
who is four years younger than me being
in the crib
and
mom and dad they would always argue and
split up and dad was always
you know messing around with the
babysitters and
he came up with a game
for me to because mom was always working
so he came up with a game for me to
clean the room
and so i would help him clean the room
and when it came time to clean the
make the bed and he would tell me that i
was
his daddy's little girl and that he
loved me
and one thing it progressed over time
from then until my second grade year
he molested it started out with just
having me you know do oral sex with him
and everything and then once i got older
he raped me and i screamed and he told
me if he wanted
the whole trailer part to know that he
would have done it in the street
for me to shut up and he hit me
um i learned
later that he was molesting my brother
and sister at the same time
because he had told me that if i shut up
and did what he told me to do
that he wouldn't mess with my brother
and sister
and that i was special and that he loved
me
um like i said as i grew up i found out
that
he had been messing with my brother and
sister as well
my mom left my dad for a little bit and
her boyfriend
molested me and
beat my brother he had hung my brother
up on
the back of the door where the little
clothes hook
had hung him up on it and my brother
tried to
in a dress he dressed him up as a little
girl
and hung him up and my brother wound up
falling off
the back of the door breaking his legs
and then she wound up going back to my
dad
where he continued to molest me and
we were staying with my grandparents
and it was during summer vacation
and my mom we had moved from milton
florida
my mom and dad and everybody had moved
from milton florida
to texas where his family was
and we were down in milton visiting my
grandparents for the
summer and my brother wound up telling
my
aunt what had happened and she had me
tested
and everything and told me not to worry
about everything was going to be okay
and my grandparents took us back to my
mom and dad anyway
and when they left dcf
had come by and left a card
and everything and
my dad was irate
and he went down the hallway hollering
about who had lied
and my brother stood up for me and said
that he had said it so my dad beat him
um
pretty bad my brother stood in the paint
for me that day
and um
uh
sorry um it's okay
we went to the dcf office
and we had to explain what happened
with little bears and dolls and stuff
about what happened and i remember
sitting in a room with my mom
under a table and could hear my dad
across the hallway screaming and crying
and saying he never did that
and my mom looking at me
and telling me look what you did to your
dad you need to tell them the truth stop
lying
and they came out and said that
they would take us
you know into the waiting room and
everything for us not to leave and
my mom and dad decided we were gonna
leave anyway
and so we left and went and hit my
dad's moms and they came
and found us and took us and put us in
foster homes
which we did from like i said second
grade up until fifth grade
and then in some of the foster homes one
of my foster parents
um molested me
one of the foster brothers
i had a crush on and i learned
that if i had sex or did what they
wanted then i got what i wanted
[Music]
so
[Music]
it was nothing for me to sleep with an
uncle
or a foster brother when i say uncle i
mean
a foster uncle or a foster dad
to be able to get what i wanted
and then when i grew my
we went home to my grandpa's house
and once we got to the children's home
i slept around a lot it was
you know um
if you love me then this is what you'll
do and
you know all i could hear was my daddy's
saying your daddy's a little girl you
know you love me and i love you and
this is what you do when you love
somebody
so that's what i did i had sex
all the time when i was
12
i was in the children's home and i was
sleeping around with a 16 year old
and got pregnant
and they um
did an abortion um
because i was so young
um i went to live with my mom
me and my brother and sister when
i was in the ninth grade and my stepdad
came up to me one day
and had i was sitting on the edge of the
bed because
it was very strange you have to
understand that
i was raised that you
do whatever it takes to make
the man of the house happy
and so i would rub my stepdad's feet
and would cook and would go with him
places
and would dance with him and everything
and rub his back if he needed his back
rubbed
and one day i was sitting on the edge of
the bed and
he put his arm around me and touched my
breast and
asked me what i thought about
if what i thought my mom would think if
i had a baby with him
because it would still be her bloodline
and he wanted a baby
so i left
and that was my senior year of high
school
i left and went to live with a lady
across the street
she was an older lady and
when i graduated i went to live with my
cousin
and went to college for a little while
and got pregnant
um
i had messed around with this guy named
well this guy
and dustin's father
my son's father and i got pregnant
and i broke up with him because he was
drinking and doing drugs
and i didn't want to be a part of it so
i went home to my family's house and i
had been seeing this guy who was 11
years older than me
and um
he said that he would take me and my
baby and would love us as their as his
own
[Music]
so
i wound up marrying my son's actual
father
and then left him about a month later
after he got me thrown out of my house
and threw a rod in my motor and tried to
run me over
while i was pregnant
so i left him and
wound up back at my mom's house
she had left my step-dad and
um
they're since dad the one that
is his dad not his blood dad but his
his dad he's got his name he adopted him
and everything such a good man
and i still wanted to drink and
was cheating all the time
and it was like
sex wasn't sex didn't mean anything
anymore it was just
i had to have it all the time
and i've been on medications
for depression
and ptsd for a long time since i was
little
and i had stopped taking my meds and was
drinking
and i left
my husband and took my son with me
and he was eight years old at the time
and
he wasn't happy and i wanted him to be
happy
and i loved him and
i was talking to this guy on
the webcam in
california and
he said that him and his family had an
arrangement
to where that if you ask
the person if they wanted to have
sex then it was okay
especially if you loved them and you
were just showing them
your love
i don't make excuses for what i did
and because what i did was wrong
i know that now
and part of me knew that then but
i just wanted my son to love me
[Music]
so i asked my son if he would have sex
with me
he was eight years old
so the guy he my dad
had come back in the picture
and i was an adult
and i was sleeping with my father
as an adult
he came by the house one night
and it scared me so
i told the guy i was talking to on the
webcam
about it and he said that if i had sex
with my son
and he could watch that he would
bring us to california and take us away
from everything
and i wouldn't have to be around my dad
anymore
so i asked my son
and we had sex
in front of the webcam for the guy to
watch
and he was telling us what to do
um
he was so young
and i took the most precious thing in
the world away from him
and every day
i wish i could take it back and give it
back to him
we go he's
i went to prison they never found the
guy
in california
we had ran after everything happened we
stopped
and we never talked about it
and we ran to wichita kansas
to some other people i had been talking
to on the computer
and it was a brother and sister and we
went there
and i got a job as an escort
to make money it was during christmas
time
and i had put my son in school
and was working and i came home one day
for christmas
and got into a big fight with the people
we were staying with
and wound up having
to um go to one of my john's
house
and he watched my son because i knew
that i was getting arrested because i
punched
the guy in
wichita they have a rule that
or a law that if there's domestic
violence
there has to be an adult witness
and i didn't have an adult witness
showing that he had hit me
but he had won his sister showing that i
had hit him
and he was mentally handicapped so
they arrested me
and put me on probation and i went to
texas to go stay with my sister for a
while
and i couldn't take care of dustin
anymore
every time i looked at him all i could
see was what i did
so i sent him to his dad's house
and his dad took care of him
and has taken care of him ever since
my son has done the same crime
that i did i don't know if it was a
little boy or a little girl
but when he was 13 he molested a child
and then when he was older
he robbed a place
right now he's married he's
got a great life
he's 27 now
[Music]
every now and then we talk
he uh
he says that you know that he's forgiven
me for what i did but it's hard to
forget
and it's the same way with my father i
talk to
him every now and then but
it's still he won't admit what he did
he said it was all fabrications from my
aunts and
everybody and that they had told me lies
but i know that it was the truth
i just i wish that somebody would have
told me when i was young
that i didn't have to
have sex with people just to make them
happy or to
make them love me
and that that wasn't what true love was
and that my dad
was sick for what he did and that i was
sick for what i did
my son's breaking the cycle
i just want you know people to know that
they don't have to follow
they don't have to go they don't have to
do
and feel
that way i have a
i still have nightmares
and flashbacks of my father molesting me
sometimes to the point to where i crawl
under tables and hide
or that's where i'm bound
um i'm doing better
i'm married i'm on medication now
and me and my husband
co-own a surveying company
so
[Music]
that's basically my story
what emotions do you struggle with the
most
hatred
on me because i still see myself as a
monster
i don't see myself as
as any of my friends see me
i still see myself as what my dad did to
me
hatred and sadness that i lost
20 years 20
very special years with my son
for something that happened for 10
minutes
of my life but destroyed his forever
so
i can't
i can't and i know my son says he's
forgiven me
and that he loves me but i can't forgive
myself for that
no matter how much
how much good there is or how much you
know
kindness there is or how much or
whatever
to me i'm always going to be that
monster
and it doesn't matter
what anybody says they've tried
but hatred and sadness
it's hard to cry now because i'm on so
much medication
but
i can still i don't even have to close
my eyes and i can still see my son
trusting me
and i destroyed all of that
[Music]
i don't see how that can
just go away
all
you've been on both ends you've been
both the victim and the predator
what what what's your view on
the
the chain of destruction that follows
after something like this happens to a
child it's devastating
it changes your whole life
[Music]
like i said if one if one person would
have said
and took the time to listen
and not just placate everything and say
oh well
here's some medicine and you know
everything's gonna be okay and
we won't talk about it but actually
listen
then maybe it wouldn't have happened
but i can't you know it's that whole
coulda shoulda woulda maybe
you know the hindsight's 20 20
thing um
but not everybody
[Music]
molests someone that's been molested
like my brother and sister they haven't
you know they live healthy lives
and
but it's it's a disaster it's
it's destructive it's
and unless someone stops it and says
and and listens to
the victim and actually listens to them
and not just you know
okay well everything's going to be fine
here take this and don't talk about it
anymore
it sure isn't healthy
i do believe most of the people when i
was in prison
most of the girls that were in there
for a sex offense were molested when
they were little
i would say nine out of ten
you did prison time for what happened
with your son i did nine years in prison
how did that come out that
you got caught my son
was at the ymca
and him and some boys were talking
and somehow sex came up
and he said that he had had sex
and the boys were ragging him and said
no that he hadn't
and he said he had had sex with his mom
[Music]
and they went to the counselors with the
ymca and the ymca
called um dcf there in texas
and then
i've seen him through the glass wall
and they let me see
you know with supervision and everything
and i told him the one thing that i
always wanted to hear from my father
and i told him that i was proud of him
[Music]
for telling the truth
[Music]
my daddy never ever said he was sorry
and i wasn't sorry because i got called
i was sorry because
i had hurt it was so bad
and he was so confused because he
thought that everything was fine
he felt just like i did when i was
little
and i had to hear that out of my son's
mouth
thank you
he didn't think anything was wrong
he didn't think he had done anything
wrong
and i had to tell him
and i remember we were sitting on a
swing it was the last time i seen him
and i told him that i was sorry
and that i was proud of him
for telling the truth
[Music]
he had just turned nine
there's nothing more devastating than
looking at your son
and seeing confusion
and love and hurt
all at the same time you're not supposed
to see that
you're not supposed to do that to your
child
you're supposed to love and nurture your
child and make them feel
safe
not destroy their life
and that's what i did
hmm
how much prison time did you do
i'm a little over nine years
and i'm 15 years probation
i've been out the 10th of december i'll
be out eight years
that time with your son was it were
there
was there alcohol or drugs involved or
alcohol
and you have problems with drugs or
alcohol yeah you do
i just when the drugs i did were
pot and occasional um
where they put the coke inside the joint
primo yeah and uh
but i was an alcoholic
i had alcohol everywhere
so many times
between that and the pills
it was like i couldn't
[Music]
i couldn't drink enough to make
everything go away
i couldn't take enough pills to make it
go away
i couldn't get high enough to make it go
away
this was after the incident with your
son or from from the incident with your
dad
both
the the nightmares now
kind of bleed over it's like it starts
with my father and ends with me
so it's hard to uh
[Music]
to differentiate those two
because i see myself as as him
how bad do the feelings of guilt and
shame
get for you sometimes
i
after the incident with my son
i had tried to kill myself
i i didn't know how to do it i took
pills and drank alcohol
wound up my friends found me passed out
and the doctor said that if i hadn't
passed out that i would have went into
cardiac arrest
i had stopped eating and was
taking pills
and my uh
magnesium and potassium levels were so
low
if i hadn't passed out i would have went
into cardiac arrest which
at the time is what i wanted
um
[Music]
i have stepped out in front of a moving
vehicle
trying to kill myself
um
[Music]
took a had a knife
and was fixing to slice my wrist and my
mom walked in on me
when i was in prison
they kept me when i was in county jail
before they sent me to prison
because i was looking at natural life
and they kept me
in like suicide watch
i never did anything
i was too chicken i wanted to
i would just seclude myself in the room
and wouldn't talk to nobody or wouldn't
see anybody
there are days when
i wish i won't wake up
they're fewer and far between now than
they used to be
i go to counseling and talk to a doctor
which has really helped and i take my
ptsd medicine
and my depression bipolar medicine
so it kind of keeps me in an
even kill i drink every now and then but
i know
that i can't
um i can't get drunk
does that make sense like i could have a
glass of red wine with dinner
but i know that that's all i can have is
that glass of red wine
and you stop there and i have to stop
there and i
i have a good support system now with my
husband
and my mom
and they helped me with that
it doesn't go away
it doesn't matter it just gets worse
it just gets worse
all right tracy thank you so much for
sharing your story
well i just hope that it helps somebody
somewhere
maybe i'm sure it will
thank you thank you
you